hello there today we're going to look at
this paper tree ring watermarks
fingerprints for diffusion images that
are invisible and robust this is by
Eugene Wen John kirchenbauer Jonas guy
ping and Tom Goldstein of the University
of Maryland in very brief overview this
paper proposes a watermark technique for
images of generative models specifically
of diffusion models and while other
Watermark techniques usually take the
image that comes out of a diffusion
model and do some sort of modification
to it as a post-processing step this
paper it enters right from the beginning
so it goes at the source into the latent
space into the noise space of the
diffusion model watermarks it there lets
the diffusion process run forward and
thus that signal is not distinguishable
either by the human and also much more
robust to post-processing attacks or
perturbation attacks I'm going to go
look at a bit of a review of diffusion
models themselves because it's important
to understand what happens here and then
we'll go into how this technique works
it's a pretty basic technique in itself
but it is quite effective and I find it
quite
quite ingenious of how this is done so
let's start from the top the authors
here they State these diffusion models
they obviously can generate images and
they get very much better day by day and
there has arisen the need for tracing
whether or not an image is generated by
a given model so there is tracing in
this case they say there's copyright
preventing potential harm from AI
generated content or simply you want to
know whether or not a given image was
produced by one of these models now the
setup we're going to have right here is
the following is that the model is going
to be behind an API so this is the model
and there is some sort of an API that
people can use in order to generate
pictures so people will make a call here
and they will get an image out of that
this the technique works like this so
the weight of the model need to be
hidden and need to be only available to
the uh person who does the watermarking
otherwise naturally anyone can just use
the model and produce images without the
watermarks and and thus watermarking
would be kinda useless I mean even if
the model is available at least you can
then Watermark things that the that are
behind this API in any case our notion
considers that it's behind an API people
call the model via some sort of APR web
interface and get an image out now this
image right here if we have watermarked
it correctly so if the watermarking
process at the location of the model
happened correctly then for this image
we can always prove that it in fact was
created by this model so we'll implant
some kind of signal some kind of a
hidden signal in that image that the end
user neither notices so it's invisible
or indiscernible nor do they have an
easy power of making it go away so let's
say even if you tell someone hey by the
way I've watermarked this image uh it's
not they don't necessarily they can't
necessarily make it go away easily and
the main advantage of the method we're
going to look at today is that second
part so even if I tell you that I have
watermarked this image it is very
difficult and you'll see a borderline
impossible with without strong
perturbations to make it go away even
under strong perturbations it's usually
recoverable
so what does this watermarking technique
do
it's quite simple it goes into the into
the latent space as I said of a
diffusion process so in very basic terms
we're going to first look at what
diffusion models do because we needed to
understand what this watermarking
technique does in a diffusion model
what you'll do is you'll train a model
to step by step produce an image from
random noise so you'll start with a
image let's just consider it of the same
size of random noise so this is just
random gaussian noise every pixel you
sample from a gaussian and then you go
through it step by step so in every step
you remove a little bit of noise every
step every step
until after many steps slowly and image
forms like here in this case that the
teddy bear we just saw this may seem a
bit like magic if you've never seen the
fusion models work or don't know why
they work but yes we have a model that
takes in an image that is initially just
pure random noise and then by repeated
application of that model we transform
that noise into a image
why does this work because of the way we
train it the way we train this is we
actually take images from the data set
so let's say we take an image from a
house and we corrupt it by a little bit
of noise so we add we add a little bit
of noise in this case Epsilon noise and
that gives us the same image with just a
little bit of noise
and then what we do is we train a model
to take in this image and give back the
image before the noise right that's
doable that's doable with deep learning
we can take a little bit of a corrupted
noisy image and we can ask you know
what's the uncorrupted version of that
image okay so we have a one step noise
remover we can also do it two steps
right we can then take that image and
add a little bit of noise again and that
will give us I should make equal signs
here that will give us the same image
with even a little bit more noise right
more noise and then we train a neural
network to recover that original image
that was only noised once so we can
create our own training data for this
process by simply starting with real
data adding noise adding noise adding
noise adding noise and then it is a
property of statistics and of
specifically also the gaussian
distribution that if we repeatedly apply
noise we have to do some scaling but if
we repeatedly apply noise over and over
again infinitely many times but you know
in practice finitely many but just many
times what we'll end up with in the
limit is just gonna be random gaussian
noise okay so that is the last piece we
need in order to make diffusion work the
mathematical fact that if I add noise
and noise and noise and noise and noise
and noise and noise over and over again
to a real data point no matter what it
is in the limit it's going to be pure
random gaussian noise following exactly
the gaussian distribution which means
that the reverse process we train right
here is exactly so that end point here
is exactly something we can actually
produce from a sampler so exactly the
starting point here and because we train
a neural network here to reverse each
step individually right we we create our
own training data for that we can then
use that to produce each step here
individually so we can simply say hey
here is the last step of here is the
pure random noise what's the one step
before that in the noise process it will
tell us and what's the one step before
that it will tell us to we just apply
that learned neural network that Network
that we trained to just reverse one step
in this noising process over and over
until we arrive at an image so this here
acts as a bit of like the random seed
um to to as an input and then the image
that's produced is going to be a
deterministic function of just applying
the reverse Network that we trained over
and over again starting from that random
seed
and it's exactly in this random seed
over here that we're going to embed some
sort of key
um and you can already see what that
does by changing the random seed will in
fact change the image that's being
produced and in in quite in quite cool
ways so the effect of this Watermark is
going to be entirely different from the
effects of other watermarking technique
that just work on the end result you can
already you know think ahead a bit of
what that's going to be so formally this
is the process we Define a noising
process so we Define the forward process
by which we mean how do we produce a
more noisy version from a less noisy
version so x t minus 1 here is going to
be the less noisy version x 0 being the
original image and XT is going to be the
more noisy version but it's pretty
simple we simply take x t minus 1 and
I'm pretty sure this here is a typo this
should actually be x t minus one
we simply take x t minus 1 and we use it
as the center of a gaussian with a
diagonal covariance which is going to be
defined by Beta here beta is a schedule
parameter it's a scheduled variance at
step T and because of the properties of
this process we have to scale
the mean right here but that's is just
so we can keep this good because if you
add noise then eventually your variance
your variance gets bigger and bigger so
we need to apply a scaling Factor but
this here is essentially the same as
saying I take
x t
minus 1 and I add Epsilon Epsilon being
a multivariate normal distribution
centered around zero and
um
and yeah with the with the variance beta
T and then I scale that or I scale it I
scale it first and then I add Epsilon
so scaling Factor times the points I
just contracted a little bit it's
centered around zero usually and then
apply
the noise
so that's the noising process taking it
adding noise
what that means is because everything's
gaussians and gaussians were composed
really nicely is that I can also jump to
any point of the process so I can take
the original image and I can say what's
the 50th step in that process and I can
just calculate that by calculating the
scaling factor and the variance factor
that I need to apply in one step so
there are just formulas where I can just
jump ahead so in that way as I said I
can create my own training data every
step in this process from image to fully
noise I can produce unsupervised just
from a set of original images and then I
can learn that one step reverse Network
so let's say we have that the property
here
so that the reverse process is here so
we have a learned noise predictor that
estimates the noise that's being added
to a single image to reach step T you
can either go back one step as I
described above or what is also possible
is you can learn to go back T steps at a
time right you can learn to go back 50
steps in one and what many current
inference methods do is they start at a
fully noised image and let's say and
they estimate what's the original image
they do it in one step they just jump a
hundred steps ahead and then maybe they
get a really crappy image because
obviously you know this is just pure
noise but then they they jump 49 steps
ahead
and then from that they infer again the
the T the X zero and then from that they
jump 48 steps ahead and so on so it
turns out that this way things tend to
be a bit more robust even even though
it's kind of less intuitive to do it
this way but also what it allows you to
do is it allows you to actually jump
steps so you can say I only want to
infer every fifth step in this process
and it can still kind of work whereas if
you were to do it step by step by step
by step you kind of have no choice but
to go down the the 100 steps you know
step by step
it's a technicality that doesn't change
anything about the math but it is just
an optimization you can do in practice
what they say is
um if if we have this learned model
sorry if we have this learned model
Epsilon this run right here again this
is the trained model that removes one
step of noise or X steps of noise
if we have that if we train that because
we created our own training data
they say it is also possible to move in
the opposite direction
we can describe a process that retrieves
an initial noise Vector which maps to an
image close to the original image
so
maybe you've heard of Gan inversions
before and so on to recover the latent
Vector given an image this is exactly
the same so rather
than starting at some image
and well that's a crappy teddy bear
starting at some image and then just
adding noise until we have some kind of
noise we can say hey what noise do I
need to what noise should be here so
that using this reverse process using my
trained reverse process I can get back
to that image so we took training data
we noised it that's how we create
created our
training data then we learned a reverse
model that goes back to the image space
and now once we've done that we can ask
given that I have an image that I know
was produced by such a model can I
recover the exact noise that was used to
produce it so this third layer this is
like layer one creating the training
data layer 2 is actually training the
reverse model and using it and Layer
Three is can I now recover the original
noise given an image
and that you just need to recognize that
that's actually possible with this
diffusion model
um it is it is a process that
has an assumption the assumption is this
right here that's a technical assumption
it simply says these steps are small
enough that the tth step is essentially
the same has the same properties as the
t plus one step so
the neural network that learns to go
from Step 99 to 98 so to remove that
98th step of noise in that process is
essentially the same as the neural
network that remove that learns to
remove from 98 to 97 and that's a
reasonable assumption given that you
have enough steps in your diffusion
process
normally you just learn one neural
network anyway which you give like a
Time parameter rather than n different
neural networks therefore it's a
reasonable assumption to do and given
that you can in fact follow the process
back and recover the original image
they
say that's an inversion process rather
than a reverse process which is already
a used word so you started a real image
and you get the noise that was used or
would be used to produce that image
using your diffusion model note that in
this process you actually need that
diffusion model
they say interestingly they find that
the inversion also succeeds well enough
for conditional diffusion models even
when the conditioning is not provided so
if you have something like stable
diffusion where you need to input a
piece of text you can you don't even
need the text that was used you can just
take the image and reverse it and you
will still find that noise so the
process is going to be as follows
as we said before the model is somewhere
here user calls through the API the
model is going to sample an initial
noise vector then the model is going to
Mark the noise Vector with some sort of
of key they call it so they are going to
Watermark the noise Vector in this case
the noise image so I'll put some some
key in there and then they'll use the
model to produce an image
even that perturbed noise vector and
then they'll return that once the user
has it they may then use it let's say
they use it for something bad and you
want to determine later did this in fact
come from the model you would go back
here
you will go to the model you would use
the reverse process to find the noise
that it was created with and if you find
that watermark in the noise then you
know it has been created by this
particular model because no one else
that's our assumption knows the weights
of this model therefore no one else has
the ability to reverse the process and
therefore if you find that Watermark it
is a strong indication that this model
was in fact used to create that image
so how do we watermark
that's up here
we Watermark like this as I said
um
we produce the initial noise in this
case a picture of of independent
gaussian samples
then we do what they call watermarking
in Fourier space so we run a fast
Fourier transform to Fourier space now
gaussians in Fourier space are just
gaussians um that's it's a property of a
gaussian distribution so I actually
don't even know why they exactly do a
Fourier space in the first place but
let's let's assume there's some scaling
Properties or something like this
um then they add what they call a
predefined key and their predefined key
are these types of ring keys they have
various different methods of doing that
so various different variants of that
but in the easiest case they just sort
of set a ring or a number of rings here
to a given value or for example zero or
three or five and then the pattern of if
you go from the inside from the center
towards the outside so the pattern like
one zero zero minus two zero three one
like that sorry that pattern here that
would be your key so your key would be
the these values right here like one
zero zero minus two zero three one
um and you imprint that onto the latent
space as these rings in Fourier space
the reason why it's Rings is because in
Fourier space if you have a ring marking
then you are
um your invariant to certain
perturbations and they find that down
here let me find that
so these are
some some properties note you could even
do that without the Fourier space and
without rings and so on and it would
still work in principle however we're
going to use some some nice facts and
features of Fourier Transformations and
of rings in Fourier space so they say a
rotation in pixel space corresponds to
rotation in Fourier space so if you
rotate the picture then you also rotate
its its Fourier
transformed result or or its
representation in Fourier space and
therefore because we have the ring if we
transform the image or the original
noise in that case after the reverse
process the key is still going to look
the same because rotation doesn't change
anything at the at this circle
um yeah a translation in pixel space
multiplies all Fourier coefficients by a
constant complex number
so again a translation in pixel space
um is a multiplication for your space
which is again
I think a rotation oh no alpharia
coefficients okay so maybe it's a
scaling as well
that I'm honestly not sure anymore
so multiplication in four years in
complex space is certainly a rotation of
the complex number
um however what they could mean here is
that it's just like a scaling and in
that case our ring patterns would just
get bigger or smaller or or wider or
narrower but we could still detect the
basic patterns so there isn't an
invariance or an equivalence there a
dilation dilation or compression in
pixel space corresponds to a compression
or a dilation in Fourier space note the
inversion dilation here corresponds to
compression here compression here
corresponds to dilation here and the
color Jitter
um adding a constant to all pixels
corresponds to changing the magnitude of
the zero frequency Fourier mode so if I
change the entire pixel if I add like
some some constant color or I make it
just brighter I would simply change one
single Pixel in Fourier space which is I
mean a cool property because the zero
pixel here it just kind of defines the
the Baseline constant of the whole thing
so if you
um I'm sure you are aware otherwise look
into Fourier transforms they're really
really cool
so we go to Fourier space with the
original noise we add our key in that
ring fashion in Fourier space we then do
an inverse Fourier transform and thus we
arrive at what they call watermarked XT
now you can't per say anything this here
is still looks kinda noisy it's
obviously no longer Pure gaussian Noise
it's no longer of the original intended
distribution however
um it's still close enough close enough
for the model uh to produce good results
obviously we haven't trained the model
the diffusion model on that modified
distribution but it is
maybe thinkable to train something that
would take that in
um that's that's maybe another thought
for another time but can we train a
diffusion model that has these
watermarked uh
these Watermark noises as an actual
training distribution I don't know
however
from that we're just gonna run the
normal diffusion model and will get an
image and that image is just the output
of the diffusion model the only thing we
changed is the input okay we don't need
to post process anything about this
image it is already watermarked because
let's say someone uses it someone uses
that image somewhere and we want to
figure out has this image been produced
by our model even if it's perturbed but
it doesn't need to be perturbed right
what we can do is we can do that inverse
process we require the model weights for
that as we said before so only we can do
it we take the image we make the inverse
process and we read out the key so if
that image has been produced by our
model then that key will show up in if
we do the inversion plus obviously the
Fourier space it will show up in Fourier
space and then we can see whether it's
close enough to the key that we
implanted or close enough to which key
we implanted and there we can say not
only is it from our from our API but
maybe even which user or which key has
been used to Watermark that image the
the um
the interesting bit twofold first of all
as they said you don't necessarily need
a text information if the fusion model
had a conditioning text input and second
of all that even under strong
perturbation as they say here that
Fourier signal tends to be retained now
you'll see an interesting property right
here namely yes
compared to other watermarking
techniques we do in fact change the
input of the diffusion process and we
change it by quite a bit right so that
means this image here is totally
different than this this the image that
would have been produced by this image
this input right here but it doesn't
matter because it's still according
right to to the diffusion process and
the noise is still close enough to the
training distribution that actually
works so here you'll have a comparison
of different watermarking techniques and
you immediately see what's different
this is the produced image without
Watermark right now from the same noise
um from the same noise
we can
Watermark it with different techniques
so these and this here are two different
techniques of watermarking that
post-process the image so that adds
something in the Fourier space but of
the image right so you have some
modifications here or some modifications
what was somewhere in the image however
this one here is is totally different
but it's still according to the prompt
which is like some teddy bear in front
of a White House
do they have the prompt they specify it
somewhere
but the cool thing is you can see if you
zoom in you can see the watermark here
you know with these with these black
dots right or you can see the watermark
here uh show up in the image however
non-visible here because there is no
watermark in the final image it's it's a
totally different image and the original
noise specified The Watermark which also
means that if I this here if I just run
some blur or something across that or
some post-processing I can easily
corrupt that Watermark easily remove
that Watermark however here no matter
how much I blur it and so on it's still
overall the same image and that image is
the watermarked version so the way you
can think of this is that the
watermarked the watermarking method
essentially defines a new modified model
that has a different output distribution
than the original model and that output
distribution itself defines the
watermark so node 2 which is also
interesting no two watermarking methods
will kind of result in that same output
distribution so even after watermarking
there's probably applications to this
where you can kind of steer the output
distribution we just don't exactly know
how yet but it could be an additional
control and in addition to whatever
latent conditioning or whatnot is to
Define modification or filters onto the
original noise to achieve a particular
output distribution
all right
they highlight a few things here
um in patterns imprinted into Fourier
space and then of the noise Vector of
the diffusion models far more robust and
existing methods no additional training
or fine tuning required to implement I
have looked at the results right here
and I don't think the results are
necessarily worth too much going into by
the way as I said they have different
ways of in imprinting three ring zeros
gives a circular region of an array of
zeros then there is sort of random
um three ring run which has different
properties but is not invariant to some
image manipulations that's probably a
typo right here as well maybe many
should say many instead of make and then
there is three ring rings which I've
shown you which is the multiple
concentric rings and having a constant
value along each ring but all of them
they have slightly different proper
properties but may result or result in
the same principle
the experiments look such that you can
see the both in the clean and
adversarial case in the clean case most
of these methods tend to recover that
Watermark or detect that Watermark which
you would obviously even especially from
the ones that modify the output image
directly you would expect but then in
the adversarial case where someone
really tries to remove that Watermark
after a post-processing but without
knowing the model explicitly you can see
that there is a a big difference for
example here
area under curve over in the 90s and for
the other methods much lower and the
same at true true positives at one
I I think uh
is that F1 two positives one percentage
of false positive rate I'm not sure I
haven't read
here okay sorry no it's the true
positive rate when the false positive
rate is one percent of course
too dumb from
so the true positive rate at the point
where the false positive rate is one
percent so these detectors you always
have to calibrate so you calibrate them
at the point where the false positive
rate is one percent look at the true
positive rate it's in the 70s over here
and it's way below way below
so the question is what do we give up
for it like obviously we modify the
original distribution uh that gives us
good watermarks but modifying the
original distribution necessarily means
our model wasn't trained for it and
therefore there is a trade-off and you
can see this right here in FID score
um so in this case lower is better and
you'll see that
in terms of FID scores it does it is
comparable to these other other
watermarking techniques and therefore
one can at least say well it's not super
duper bad
um in fact it's probably not noticeable
and that's what you want out of a
watermarking
um water marking method they have
different experiments on robustness I
will leave those away from now just be
aware that it does in fact it is in fact
quite robust to any sort of
um to any sort of perturbation
and they do ablation studies and more so
that experimental section is quite
extensive but as I said I don't want to
go too much into this right here if
you're interested please check out the
paper for yourself
they finally discussed the limitations
they say the proposed Watermark is by
Design only verifiable by the model
owner because the model parameters are
needed to perform the inversion process
so it is not like a let's say a public
key cryptography signature where anyone
can verify that like I wrote the message
but only I can verify that a given image
was produced from my model
maybe there is in the future a way that
expands on this method that actually
achieves this they also say currently it
is not yet clear how large the capacity
for multiple Keys would be
Keys yeah and in that case
the question is okay the key I've shown
you before with the concentric Rings
right how many of those could I use and
still being able to differentiate
between all of them that is mainly a
property of how much the per how much
the perturbations affect
um
so the perturbations that an attacker
would use
the ones we saw right here so let me say
let me think I attack now I put a strong
perturbation because I want to remove
that Watermark that's necessarily going
to corrupt my ability to reverse that
process and going to corrupt the image I
get out here plus the inversion process
itself has some inaccuracies so I'll get
like an inaccurate
um reverse thing and then I have a
threshold of how close I want the two to
be together so a mixture of how strong
the perturbations should be or should it
be robust to and that threshold that I
set right here will determine how many
keys I can solidly distinguish from one
another
but it's I mean it's a property of
experimentation they just say they don't
know yet and neither do I
right that was about all I had to say of
this paper I found it a really really
cool method
um it is noticeably different it's like
a little bit I mean obviously it's kind
of obvious if you think from you know
hindsight but it is also thinking a
little bit outside the box and I think
it's also a nice a nice
applique or a nice demonstration of you
can work with modern state-of-the-art
this could have been done by a high
school student or so in a collab right
and you can absolutely work with
um state-of-the-art
models and still do really meaningful
research and write really good papers
without necessarily many resources at
your disposal you just have to be a bit
creative what exactly you investigate
the topic of whether or not watermarking
is a good thing and where it's
applicable in the first place I don't
want to touch here that was it for me
leave comments like and bye